0.981A
我看是有一個很大的問題
各位看一下這裡
其實不是他本色的問題
只要一個股票一個ETF規模
過大這個會跟當年的
00940會有點像
但是我覺得他比00940會更慘
為什麼因為他現在手上太多股票了
各位來看一下
他今天買股票我覺得相對的
跟之前不大一樣
那我們來看一下00980他之前買什麼
來看一下 台光店昨天買了300張
嘿 台光店4800塊 買300張
你看到沒有 在這位置買300張
那今天 今天為什麼跌
因為今天他沒有買啊
來來來 我們再來看一下
今天他沒有買台光店了
一不買就容易跌
跟以前的那個 我們講高股息息很像嘛
要除息就買 除完息就不買
你不買就跌
那一樣啊
這個台光店好
台光店很猛很厲害齁
這個投信啊
我們來看一下
投信好棒棒
這裡
投信一直買一直買
口口買
買到買了
沒錢買那可能又被別的投信賣一賣就一根黑K再殺下去981要不要砍股票你不砍你的績效會開始落後一些不要說大盤的啦你可能會落後其他主動型ETF
那這時候就麻煩了喔
你的績效果開始落後
欸現在那個有跟各位講
很多主動型ETF
都去電視台業配啊
為什麼
因為大家看到981這麼肥
想不到產物這麼愛
就發了一堆主動型ETF
所以呢
你在電上面看到一堆業配
哇一頭拉股業配
我業配的話我就很簡單
我就把98IA的ETF那個績效
跟我的ETF績效兩個一比
我只要怎麼樣 我只要贏他
我就說你買98IA不如買我家的
對不對 我會講
搞不好你就想跳槽
假如你跳槽 假如你賣98IA的話
他就得賣股票
各位呢 請看我的文章
我們這文章寫得很專業
48小時的抽碼追蹤
因為我昨天我特別看98IA的
他的一些交割狀況
那各位看一下
98IA呢 他在昨天的報表
他應付證券款是高達219億元
就是他要付219億元
他帳上現金153億元
欸 各位你想想看 你敢做這事情嗎
你戶頭153億 你敢買219億嗎
你敢嗎 你一定不敢嘛因為你怕違約交割嘛 對不對那為什麼他敢因為昨天有人買他的ETF所以明天會有新的錢進來那有新的錢進來 他就不怕嘛
所以買多一點嘛 你懂我意思嗎
就像說 你4月30號買股票
5月1號領薪水嘛
所以5月2號就錢交割嘛 對不對
就類似這樣子嘛 所以他敢買
好啦 就昨天這樣子喔
帳上現金153億
可是他買了交割款219億
然後4月28號
他的規模居然才增加了才增加了
增加多少?各位你看一下
他前天規模增加200億
前天規模增加200億
因為他應付證券款就200億了
你買200億當然增加200億啊
那你現在
今天怎麼樣?
單日僅增加36億
就僅增加一點點而已啊
那現金水會暴增
上現金大幅回升到271
為什麼?
因為他發現買981的人變少了
那為什麼買981人變少
因為現在一堆人還去
申購什麼0403A嘛
第一個 一堆人去申購
主動ETM 然後錢卡在那邊
不能拿出來嘛 因為你去申購就不能拿出來
那第二個怎麼樣
你看這什麼鬼啊
49萬人到六七萬人啊現在 欸一個禮拜增加多少啊1818萬戶啊增加了30幾趴啊我沒啊現在一個禮拜增加多少啊18萬戶啊增加了30幾%我沒有看過一個禮拜幾百戶數增加這麼多啊
這麼多戶這麼高的趴數
這一看就是典型的最後那種
FOMO的那種感覺啊
就像019世銀一樣
019世銀呢在當時
一堆跑進去開戶啊
那時候我就覺得019世銀完蛋了
那開戶就是問題
這不是981A的問題
是規模的問題
只要這個規模沒辦法再持續嘛
只要沒辦法再持續
沒有新的人進來
你沒有錢再買股票
你勢必只能換股
那當你換股你要怎麼換
我問你要怎麼換
你買了一堆台光電好不好
你現在981買了一堆台光電
沒辦法
只要買4800
現在剩4300耶
買300張耶
買300張今天賠多少
今天就賠1億啊
1億很少啦
很少啦 兩千多億才賠一億而已
很少啦 有沒有看到
可是問你要砍他嗎
981是這樣子喔 他砍股票他要一次砍到底喔
為什麼要這樣子
他不得不這樣子啊
因為他砍一半是要被人家痛宅啊
你懂嗎 我砍一半不是告訴人家
糟糕天下說明天還要再砍一半
那之後各位你等著看他成本股
看他成本股怎麼賣
好不好